[Music]  we begin with a shocking breakup  jennifer aniston and justin theroux  just announced it's over the decision  was made mutually and lovingly at the  end of last year the statement we are  quote two best friends who have decided  to part ways as a couple but look  forward to continuing our cherished  friendship now we thought something  might be wrong when Justin was not there  as Jen celebrated her 49th birthday last  Sunday he was in New York working she  was with her gal pals at Courtney Cox's  Malibu home give me three things great  about Justin only three yes only three  his warmth is kindness his talent she's  just a wonderful person she's kind she's  lovely  so what went wrong well Jen and Justin  don't want speculation they tell us  above all we are determined to maintain  the deep respect and love that we have  for one another  [Music]  you